welcome to this video let's go head here
d form against LM LM from China yeah
it's actually sometimes difficult to
identify the flex I mean I know the
Chinese flag but it's very very small so
you cannot really tell if they're some
stars in there or whatever okay so we
have our names own names Oh Indian with
III I think I played it this way with
III c 5 mm hip like normally get takes
on c4 on on place I think castles
yeah I have a bit of an unusual night
position here but it is helpful in
supporting d5 and here he goes
immediately trying to make use of the
night hmm nice may be intending to play
on poetry 5 you okay possible yeah maybe
he's just threatening to take f4 and
take default so it's not them completely
out of this world okay I only know maybe
maybe this is too too I'm simplifying
but I have fun slightly better
development
what I mean is if he takes twice takes
Knight takes Knight takes Knight eggs or
something has also got Queen edge from I
don't know maybe this wasn't a great
idea yeah this is an additional issue
where to go damn still to hu I thank 95
Sam is a problem but I thought it would
be am still all right yeah what I what I
thought actually was to play Bishop g5
maybe this is completely do take as
possible but maybe it is it is not so
stupid try to use the the pin
now should a force really lame move
really name
sure it is lame but I don't think I
really can sacrifice it on h2 or allow
him to take it's also for sacrifice
position of sacrifice I didn't take it
take it only three okay well okay now it
probably takes on on fo just Bishop f4
can we can play maybe you can even go g5
I can play age three I believe wow I
should have thought before that that's
not great for me anyway that's um yeah I
should have done something else as
simple as that in with other moves i
think i could have really played for
something this now is f 95 this is Sir
okay my I don't have it now this is a
shame
Queen g5 try with very simple threats oh
yeah this is this is just like sometimes
you're sometimes you're looking yeah
okay so just take the two pieces and
don't think he's got any any sort of
attack I always have Bishop g5 as well
let's let's get this set up so that done
that's really Noth right at all
97 coming
dance was really a cheap cheap trick
with Queen B 5 yeah dad died I saw g5
too late before this probably about
equal and g5 really sends white into an
immediate struggle yeah that's 25
minutes okay yeah it's not moving oh no
I actually moved okay sorry um who came
justjust him group age six I can go into
f5 threatening queen e 5 with the Queen
trade
hmm yeah nice dragging it on a bit
yup just done rookie one rupee ate two
pieces is really too much Jack Black
yeah this also made them made next month
ah yeah this wasn't too bright get g5
this video what a move g5 h3 ahead 95 I
had 95 this is a really good player
stupid what I didn't saw what I didn't
see is the following I computer
immediately gives this as the best way
and after this i'm bad and worse I can
do that what I didn't see is I thought I
thought this end oops rook c8 and i
wasn't sure i was actually this funny
move not intending to escape on f4 yeah
95 was the safe safe move it's funny
that the computer actually thinks this
is about equal it wants to play age six
and then wookie one round okay it's got
a slightly loose King position now so
it's probably not a simple we know
anything but okay 22 pieces this is
really too much okay thanks for watching